let me pull up this story here we got uh
from the post millennial oh my joe rogan
and james lindsey point out how the left
smears everyone they disagree with as
alt-right on the latest episode of the
podcast joe rogan spoke with james
lindsay about why so many people are
deemed alt-right by the left and uh the
story's about me so uh special thanks to
james and joe because i don't even think
they were necessarily defending me just
pointing out facts just denying this
what happened was this guy josh zapps
who is a statist propagandist in
australia who really doesn't like me
because i've criticized their country
and he makes things up and boy is he
triggered by me
he said you know oh tim poole says these
things and blah blah and then a few
seconds later goes so these alt-right
guys who are you know saying this stuff
and then joe cuts him off and he's like
tim paul's not all right you can't just
say that man that's not true and he's
like well i didn't mean i mean and then
he says i don't think magi nawaz is all
right i know him but tim poole
so joe rogan's talking to james and they
end up bringing me up specifically and
joe's like i know tim very well he's
like a centrist he was a boots on the
ground guy for vice and then james like
yeah he was in occupy so this is this
this is
what i think is is
it shows the the lies it's obvious
they're lying the most one of the most
powerful media uh uh
shows in the world joe rogan's show is
outright just with no uh
remorse calling out the lies
i think this is a good example of
the narrative is is breaking before our
eyes know whatever
i know there's a lot of reasons why we
said the narrative is breaking but
here's another really good one it
involves me so obviously i wanted to
highlight it and say thank you to joe
for for just being honest and talking
about you know my views and everything
but who's going to believe this anymore
well i was thinking maybe this is alt
right in the sense that it's alternative
to the to the polarized right it's more
of a center alt-right means white
nationalism that's the problem with
specifically that's the problem with the
phrase it does it shouldn't mean that
it's further right than than people on
the right it's just an alternative to
weird polarized politics that's that's
literally not the case it just crossed
my mind the associated press put out a
statement years ago saying the alt-right
group that that coined the term
specifically referenced white
nationalist ideology that's where the
term came from that's what it represents
that's why the left will try to
passively smear everyone as alt-right so
they can then add to your wikipedia page
something like ian's been called
alt-right then another outlet will say
many news organizations have noted that
ian comma who's considered alt-right
comma and then eventually they can just
say ian is alt-right then they can then
say ian is a white nationalist and put
on your wikipedia page that's the game
they play it's not working anymore it's
it's falling apart because people are
getting sick and tired of it and they're
not scared to call out the bunk media
and you know it is as the media ratings
collapse people are getting less scared
of being smeared because they're
irrelevant
it's also way to shut you up they can't
engage you with your ideas so like
someone said i don't want um i don't
want to open borders well then you're
you're uh racist because you don't like
mexican people but no because i there's
a reason why i don't think this is
effective it's it's you know racist
sexist it's all the things it's to shut
us up because they don't want to have
this debate and people on the left are
they don't they're not good at debating
because they don't get those other ideas
coming at them if you're on the right
you get all the ideas you you watch
colbert you watch the culture you read
the news you're experiencing even by
default
all these different concepts and you're
able to kind of you know
work with them talk about them debate
them but if you're on the left you're in
this bubble area and you can't debate so
you have to smear well shout out to
hunter avalone for having come on this
show a while back because you know he
made i respect him for coming on the
show and he was having you know
traditional liberal views but man don't
don't come on a show unprepared and be
arrogant about it that's what i would
say so you know the issue with him was
he brought up hunter b he brought up joe
biden hunter biden ukraine barisma and
he didn't know anything about it so when
i said joe biden did engage in a quid
pro quo a corruption
in ukraine to empower his son and make
money for his family and hunter was like
that's not true i was like bro i can
name every person i've read the reports
i've read ukrainian news i've read
russian news i've read matt tybee's
reporting i have dug through that to a
great deal
and i asked him do you know the name of
the guy who started charisma and he was
like no and i'm like okay look with all
due respect why would you step up and
claim you know something and then when i
ask you a simple question it's outright
say i don't know anything about it that
that's that's a weird arrogance that
exists but like
about it but
they don't they don't know any of this
because they don't actually have these
debates so when someone comes into a
debate and their first experience with
this is ah i remember what hassan said
he said it's not true
and then i'm like i actually can pull up
all of the facts and show you do you
want to see the ukrainian news outlets
talking about this guy fleeing the
country no they don't read the news they
don't they listen to each other and they
have a big
um circle of people who are jerks
we try to keep it family-friendly
i respect that they're very happy in
that circle but uh they're also
completely out of touch too they're on
that island to the outside
yeah yeah that's probably what happens
on that island uh to be completely
honest with you but joe biden bragged
about that i mean can we not forget that
it's amazing that joseph is like
thrilled literally he's like i did it i
had to quit pro quo and the media is
like no he didn't right
that that's you got to be a special kind
of either stupid or or deceptive
to be going online claiming it never
happened when we all watched the video
of joe biden doing it and joe biden's so
dumb he bragged about it i think the
scary thing for me about media bias
today is that we can see things or hear
things
in their context and the media will say
no it didn't happen that scares me
it really scares me well it used to
scare me now i just laugh about it but
people believe it though that's the
thing that really upsets you but their
ratings are in the gutter so i know
their ratings are still high colbert
gets like three million viewers or
whatever i just really loved when joe
biden was doing the press conference and
they were like you know if you don't
pass these voter reform bills what do
you think's going to happen joe's like
well there's very good chance it could
be illegitimate and then genseki comes
out the next day no actually he didn't
say that right what he said was trump is
the problem right it reminds me of when
that episode of family guy where um lois
griffin is running for office and she
gets gets up to the podium and she goes
9 11 and they go yeah
start clapping and cheering and then
they're like how would you deal with the
economy and she goes nine
11. yeah and those are clapping and
cheering she stole that from moody
giuliani that's not fair yeah
and i'm reminded of the orwell quote
that we talked about on the show
previously before that says quote the
party told you to reject the evidence of
your eyes and ears it was their final
most essential command and there's a lot
of truth to that especially when you see
them
call out stuff that clearly does happen
that clearly is a reality and i'm saying
no no no this never happened don't look
at the evidence don't question it if you
do you're a bad person you're a part of
the alt-right you're you know a
homophobic that means you're a white
nationalist also if you know if it does
turn out that the gop takes a lot of uh
extra seats or whatever in the 2022 in
the midterms and the democrats then
start saying that the election was
illegitimate we're going to be able to
look back on this moment and be like you
said it wouldn't be now what are you
talking about you know it's like it's
just such a little trap for them i want
to give a special shout out to the
disinformation cycle it starts with the
new york times reporting that ukrainians
were interfering in the us election to
benefit hillary clinton uh that was it
was actually let me be very careful and
precise it was politico that reported
this it was the new york times that also
reported that a ukrainian court had
found that uh certain interests in
ukraine or individuals were engaged in
this behavior and then it comes to ted
cruz who appears on meet the press and
he and he's asked by um
who's the guy meet the press what's his
face
the guy chuck todd is it chuck chuck
is it church i don't know he's asked do
you really believe that ukraine
interfered in the election and ted cruz
is like politico in the new york times
reported they did and then you hear one
of the producers at msnbc start laughing
or nbc just start laughing and then i'm
just like
ted cruz cited mainstream news and they
laugh at him like he's wrong because
they don't read the news then our good
friend david pakman does a segment about
it where he's like i can't believe how
dumb ted cruz there's no laughing at him
and i'm like david did you google the
stories they're real
but they don't read the news
so they're like those of us that read
the news like on this show we have an
eclectic bunch of people of varying
political beliefs and we read the news
so we kind of agree on what some of the
basic facts are like many of them
and then we disagree on policy positions
but that's just it's right wing it's
just shuffle everyone into the alt-right
bucket if you read the news well we read
the same news that's the problem is
there's lots of news out there that i
don't read that doesn't never comes up
on this show or is even orbited on this
show because it's just it seems fake it
seems like media narrative i don't know
i read like i read
not yesterday morning because i had food
poisoning but most mornings i read all
the i read at least the headlines of
pretty much everything
real quick
just put a pin real quick i want to
mention we've cited npr we've cited
nj.com we've cited uh uh so we've hinted
at mother jones we've hinted at reuters
yo we use establishment press on this
show we just fact checked these stories
like the other day i specifically
pointed out that i used npr on purpose
for one source i use cnn on purpose if i
can fact check what cnn says and and
find it to be true i'll use them as a
source to say okay not tell me cnn's
wrong it's one of the funniest things i
was i was accused of peddling
misinformation about the election
because i quoted cnn that's the point so
i could be like wow cnn's fake news i
guess but anyway sorry no no i just i
check everything in the morning i check
fox i check npr i check the new york
times and washington post check daily
wire
i check through everything we ran
overnight that at the post-millennial
that i didn't see do you go website to
website or do you like look at it
through a portal honestly like i have it
on my phone oh cool so like i just check
everything i don't check i always check
reuters my reporting on ukraine and
everything i read
politico reported that ukrainians did uh
interfere in the election and the new
york times ruled a court in ukraine had
found that to be true as well that's the
new york times in politico i'm not i'm
not cherry-picking my new sources
i actually look for counterpoints there
aren't any so i went to ukraine and i
hit up a source i had in ukraine said
can you investigate this from local news
sources and then when i reported on it i
said i don't know the the the
credibility of these outlets it's a
local ukraine outlet i'm not familiar
with but this is what they reported it
backs up what our these national outlets
politico and new york times have said
so for me for everybody here
i think the the issue for us is that we
actually fact check the stories so we
have an understanding of reality but
when
you know chuck todd on meet the press
laughs at ted cruz or his producers do
because ted cruz cited the new york
times
that's a special level of stupid coming
out of nbc
it's interesting that the and very own
brand to think that a corporation would
feed you a little bit of falsity get you
to believe it and then ridicule you for
believing it
well there's been a lot of crazy news
stories of them just absolutely
inverting reality to what is just
totally the complete two seconds
exactly and it's not that hard to fact
check it's not that hard to to look at
sources it's not that hard to get a
different side of the story uh it's
becoming more and more difficult
especially when it comes to using google
uh and i think they're catching on to
that but the
we have an opportunity in our life where
we have this small window that's closing
where we could look up anything at any
moment and find out exactly what we want
about it
that window i believe is closing it's
still here we should still use it as
much as we can two seconds i can pull up
these stories from political new york
times mainstream establishment outlets
talking about this very fact that nbc
their talking heads make fun of ted cruz
for there's a lot of things you can make
fun of ted cruz for don't get me wrong
but he wasn't wrong on the facts so when
pundits like david pakman go on his show
and he laughs at ted cruz for being
right i'm just like i i messaged david
and i was like hey like here's the link
to the stories bro like you just had to
google it i don't understand why you're
laughing at ted cruz or mocking him
there's something about this story this
uh biden ukrainian scandal that's a
little vague that makes me tired
whenever it comes up like i feel like it
requires more glucose to process the
information for some reason i don't know
why i know what you mean
it does kind of feel that way it's like
it's layered it's it's complicated it's
not a great thing certain stories are
just like a punch to the face this one
it's more requires people you gotta dig
in you know to explain this story to my
friend's dad i was like have a seat sir
list of characters because what happens
is you can start slow and let them ask
you questions like
a video emerged of joe biden bragging
about engaging in a quid pro quo where
he would withhold a billion dollars in
us aid to ukraine unless they fired a
prosecutor that's extortion right uh
well you can call it whatever you want
it's illegal okay that joe biden doesn't
have the authority to stop something
that's not it's not extortion if the
president does it right no but he wasn't
president at the time this was back when
he was vice president was vice president
and the vice president and president
can't go and say i am going to
personally halt an act of congress
so they accused trump of doing that when
in fact joe biden literally did it and
we know he did and he bragged about it
and then the media comes on says joe
biden never did that and he wanted the
prosecutor fired because the prosecutor
was investigating burisma where his son
was a chair was like a you know on the
board there and victor shoken the
prosecutor in ukraine who got fired
signed a sworn affidavit saying the
president came to me and said joe biden
wants you fired because you're
investigating barisma matt taibi
reported this and he reported there were
a dozen plus investigations from the
prosecutor into barisma every step of
the way there have been sycophantic
establishment journalists who have been
like well burisma wasn't even under
investigation and then journalists are
like here's the investigations yeah well
but those were uh not about uh
what were they investigating them for
so my close my colo zlatchevsky is just
the general surface answer is corruption
kickbacks forge documents just you name
it when it comes to trying to steamroll
things through i don't i i my personal
view of this after everything i've read
walking the story back to explain to
like my friend's dad it's the cutter
turkey pipeline it's trying to get
natural gas into europe trying to
compete with russia and the gas prop a
gas prom natural gas monopoly it's
around 20 that goes into europe comes
from gazprom through ukraine so us
interests nato western allies wanted to
get an alternative source of fuel to
lower the prices they needed a means to
do it so they prop up this com this
company they have a guy who engages in a
little you know behind the scenes to
make it work faster there's like a cia
director who's on the board along with
hunter biden who has no business being
on the board and in the era of the
internet we can learn these things they
got really mad it was happening joe
biden some [ __ ] and bragged about it
and all of a sudden it looks like you
can see at least the surface of what
they were trying to do with syria with
turkey with iraq with iran with with
ukraine what they're still trying to do
with ukraine trump really messed all
those plans up because trump i just
think didn't care about their plans saw
the video of joe biden engaging in what
appeared to be illegal activity and is
illegal activity and then called the
president of ukraine and said i saw this
video this was literally happening he's
like i saw this video of joe biden
saying who's gonna do this can you look
into that for me and then they were like
impeach him we gotta impeach him now and
then they handcrafted this insane story
about trump quid pro quo which was
actually joe biden here's the best part
people on youtube and facebook and
twitter who named the cia guy and don't
say his name please they got all their
content deleted i had videos deleted for
telling the story i made a post
you you post any of these stories and
they would disappear without warning it
was so obvious what they were doing i
figured out why it has been confusing me
is because they've been blaming trump
for the same thing that biden does yes
exactly amazing watching it happen like
being in the news and it's like joe
biden walks over and kicks a dog and
then the media goes breaking news trump
kicked a dog and i'm like
but what well i mean
and now biden is
definitely gonna go to war for ukraine
that's amazing
it's usually for oil for a resource if
it's trump or trump wasn't supposed to
win
trump was not supposed to win i was i
was in uh uh ukraine at the maidan
protests when all this is erupting when
yanukovych got ousted when ukraine was
was was in that turmoil period and it
was that western forces and this is just
my opinion as one person who covered a
little bit of it i'm probably wrong a
lot of this but my view was
obviously the west wanted to get ukraine
under the fold they want to get cheaper
gas into europe that was part of the
plan russia doesn't want that to happen
it's against their interests syria is
allied with russia this whole region is
embroiled in this conflict trump gets
elected everything stops
syria he's trying to withdraw our troops
from syria they won't let them they lie
about it trump is like why do i care
about ukraine just give him some weapons
and be done with it biden gets back in
and all of a sudden oh no
it's like the amazing thing is after
trump got elected the whole ukraine
civil war narrative stops
and just like goes off the news cycle
biden gets back in and here we are
ukrainian civil war all over again yeah
it's back amazing but there was still
fighting between uh
in ukraine between some russian forces
and the separatists yes but i went there
but but it was still at a standstill
compared to two of how hot it was
comparatively to when uh you know john
mccain was there and i went to ukraine
uh uh i think i went there it may have
been just before trump got elected
and in this period my sources on the
ground just locals they're not like
experts said the fighting had mostly
subsided and they were no longer they
said don't call it a civil war that
pisses people off and i was like when i
was here and when i left it escalated
that point where the the eastern
separatist no no no no it's just it's
separatist conflict and it's like you
know it's anti-government extremism like
oh okay and then for years we barely
hear anything about it joe biden gets in
and all of a sudden we're being told
russia's about to invade ukraine
okay dude yeah they were going at putin
until trump got elected then they were
going at trump for being connected to
putin then trump left now they're going
back at putin this whole boogeyman thing
is so annoying
well
one of the things is
you've got the bureaucratic state the
intelligence agencies they have plans
that exist well beyond yeah i think
they're playing a 100-year game as well
as the ccp i think they're both playing
the 100-year game trump was not supposed
to win when trump got in office all of a
sudden their plans were completely
disrupted so anyway this all started
because i i obsess over this stuff
because this was one of the most
egregious things that's ever happened in
american history a president was
impeached
over a lie to maintain bureaucratic
policies that existed before he got in
office and it just shows you that the
emperor has no clothes no one's playing
by the rules anymore and any semblance
of like
like yo if you think the president has
real power you need you underestimate
the intelligence agencies and the
bureaucratic state that that's what we
can see here that beyond the president
they they there's a reason why trump was
jammed up the entirety of his first term
because trump was not supposed to be the
guy to win and he wanted to show up our
borders he wanted to bring the troops
home he wanted to go america first build
up our factories and he did not want to
play that international game and they
got mad about it so everything that
accused him of working with russia which
was a lie then they did the impeachment
then they did the other impeachment and
now they're trying to prosecute him over
fraud in new york so he can't run for
office
it's crazy thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time